It's great to welcome to the program today.
Jerry Mitchell, whose stories have helped
put poor Klansman and a serial killer behind
bars.
There's that's an introduction aching for
more detail, Jerry Scio.
I appreciate the opportunity to talk to you.
It's great to talk to you.
So tell us a little bit about your investigative
work.
And you wrote the book Race Against Time,
which tells the story of Ku Klux Klan murders
that went unpunished during the civil rights
movement.
Talk a little bit about how you got into this
space and how this all developed.
Yeah, it's.
It kind of a couple of things happen in pretty
close proximity.
The first being I happened to see the movie
Mississippi Burning, which is a fictional
film about the killings of three young men,
civil rights workers killed by the Klan in
Mississippi, James Chaney, Andrew Goodman
and Mickey Schwerner.
And they were killed on the first day of summer
in 1964, which was also part of Freedom Summer,
which was very important to the civil rights
movement in terms of college students coming
down.
And one of those.
But basically no body.
The thing that shocked me watching Phil and
I happen to be sitting by an FBI agent, by
the way, investigate the case, which is another
wild thing in retrospect.
But I was shocked to discover more than 20
Klansmen more involved than killing nobody
ever been prosecuted for murder.
That is the part I just couldn't wrap my head
around.
David artists.
Was that I?
I mean, they're going back, however far back
you want to go.
How common was it that the perpetrators in
lynchings, et cetera, were just never prosecuted?
Extremely common.
But I was woefully ignorant and I just didn't
know it.
You know, this was all news to me at the time
in nineteen eighty nine.
And so, you know, I grew on my little, you
know, white bread world and East Texas, and
I didn't know it either, you know.
And so here I am plopped in Mississippi on
this new job and.
Anyway, it's all news to me, and I'm just
a lowly reporter and just, you know, stumble
across this and so I start reporting about
that and about the same time I found out about
this.
If you're like me, but if someone tells me
I can't have something like a million times
worse.
Right.
So there are some Mississippi called the Mississippi
Sovereignty, which was the state segregation
spy agency.
And there were like a hundred and thirty two
thousand pages of records that the Mississippi
legislature sealed for 50 years.
So when I found that out, my first thought
was, well, there's something in there.
You heard the door and we sail in for 50 years
otherwise.
So I had developed sources and began to leak
me the files.
And what they showed was at the same time,
same as it was prosecuted, Byron De La Beckwith
for murdering Medgar Evers, this other arm
and State Sovereignty Commission was secretly
assisting the defense, trying to get back
with acquitted.
Nobody knew that.
And so my story ran October 1st.
Eighty nine.
And that's basically the case got reopened.
That's kind of the short version.
And when it comes to I mean, so there's a
few cases that you've worked on, so-called
cold cases that you started researching on
and researching and reporting on.
At what point during these what is the step
that makes it so that it is officially reopened
and being reinvestigated?
That kind of opens the door once again.
Right.
Well, in the case of the Medgar Evers case,
it was this revelation that helped to kind
of pry open that you buy it kind of.
One thing led to another early.
Evers asked for the case to be reopened.
The newspaper declaring closure where I was
working, editorialized for the city council,
voted for it.
And basically, the D.a.'s office by the end
of the month said he was reopening the case.
But it really didn't kind of tie begin to
turn until months later when the discovery
of the Beckwith brag to a Klansman about killing
Medgar Evers.
And so that kind of began to turn the tide.
It was tentatively reopened.
Do you think was going to happen?
And that's really what did.
So when you start investigating some of these
cases, what type of investigative work are
you doing?
Are you are you saying who can I talk to?
Are you interviewing witnesses?
Is it a lot of data and research work?
Yeah.
We're like, for example, I was able to get
a copy of the transcript.
Myrlie Evers shared widow of Medgar Evers.
And so that was really helpful.
I went and interviewed the police officers,
for example, and gave Beckwith an alibi.
And they their story differed from what they
one of them differed from what he had told
back in.
For the trials.
Now, those officers even agree to talk to
you.
Well, I guess you have to ask them.
I don't know.
Yeah, I.
I think as someone wrote about me one time
versus those years ago for my Harold, pretty
much.
Why are Leider.
Well, will look like Opie, you know.
So I mean, I think I came across as kind of
a horrible guy, you know, in their eyes and
certainly suther.
So anyway, they were they welcomed me.
And at different points, as these cases start
to shift from being unlikely to ever having
a resolution to, hey, this is being looked
into to, hey, there could be charges coming.
Do you worry about your personal safety?
Well, my wife at the time certainly did.
She was concerned I was going to be killed.
And in retrospect, I understand a little better
than I did at the time.
You know, she was here.
I am going to interview the killer of Medgar
Evers.
She was eight, eight, eight months prior.
Protect her son.
So, yeah, I you know, I didn't take it really
into account.
But but speaking of Beckwith, I went and interviewed
him.
And so, yeah, there were some frightening
moments.
When I when I interviewed Beckwith, I spent
about six hours with him.
Absolutely.
Most racist person I ever spent time with.
And it was six hours later.
It's dark.
You insist on walking me out to the car.
And I'm like, Really?
That's OK.
After the car, he says, Iraq positive things
about why Caucasian Christians.
God will bless you.
If you read negative things about white Caucasian
Christians, God will punish you.
God does not punish you directly.
Serve several individuals will do it for him.
Right.
I was going to say if it was just going to
be left to God, that's one thing.
But he's making it clear that that may have
helped God out.
So, I mean, I have so many different aspects
of things that I want to ask about.
But in in your investigation, in some of these
conversations, you know, one of the interesting
things that at least today is not often told
about the history of the civil rights movement,
the Mississippi Burning cases is an interesting
example, is that there were a lot of Jewish
folks who were working with the civil rights
movement.
And in fact, sometimes the victims, including
in Mississippi Burning, are presumed to be
black Americans, but are Jewish folks.
Did you in your work on these cases also encounter
that anti-Semitism was just completely wrapped
up with the anti black racism?
Oh, yeah.
In fact, I didn't.
I'm kind of shortening these stories.
But when I talk to Byron, deal back with,
he was really almost really more anti Semitic
than he was anti black, anything.
It wasn't white pretty much, but he was a
part of what's called Christian identity.
And he Beckwith's is not alone on that.
The Klan was also believe this.
A Christian identity is essentially just a
horrible racist religion.
They believe that Adam and Eve were white
people.
They believe that all the other nonwhite races
are mud people, quote unquote.
They're like animals and ahum souls.
And then they believe.
I mean, this is where it gets really rank
and horribly racist toward the Jews.
They believe that Jews are liberal offspring
of Satan.
Right.
You know what's interesting about hearing
you say mud people?
I think it was more than 10 years ago I interviewed
this guy named Glenn Miller, who since has
been arrested, of course, for killing people
he believed were Jewish, but in fact, were
not.
I asked him, you know, from your perspective,
is, is the real threat the black folks or
the Jewish folks?
And it was sort of like hard for him to even
say, like there was just a lot of it.
It's not even clear he had it straight, but
they were all muddy people.
That's the exact word that he used.
Mm hmm.
And as they're common, there's a common term,
a Christian identity.
And that's what they believe.
It's you know, they believe that white people
are the true Israelites.
It just gets very strange hint.
Are you following the logic of it?
There's not really logic.
But yes, you are correct.
I believe it.
But people are very anti Semitic.
I mean, there's a really good book on several
good books.
A good point, too, but Blood in the Face.
James Ridgeway Road, which talks about, in
fact, Beckwith brought that term up to me.
That's why they believe it's white people,
because white people can blush.
And then and then there's a book.
Jack Nelson wrote some years ago called Terror
in the Night, which was about basically the
Klan in Mississippi where originally attacking
African-Americans as well as white sympathizers.
But then they really shifted their focus to
attacking the Jews.
They began to bomb synagogues, Bob, Jewish
leaders, homes and things like that.
Were any of the Klansmen blindsided by charges?
In other words, was while you were working
on stuff?
Did people start to get a catch wind of what
was going on?
Yeah.
They started getting increasingly nervous.
OK.
And or stop talking to me at certain points,
you know.
My idea was to get in there early.
I wanted to talk to the killers.
I wanted to hear what they.
He had to say and keep them talking.
And there are just big is just certain points.
I know we had it actually because we stopped
talking to me.
But we had another reporter who went and actually
was sitting there almost.
Right.
Went back with he got a call that basically
he was going to get arrested and he was like,
they sent the reporter away.
Back with us.
Back with his wife.
Fuming.
Yeah.
So it's it's fascinating to hear all this
as it unfolds.
I think that there will be people who listen
to our conversation and they will maybe envision
that the era you were investigating was a
different era.
Were things you know, people don't get away
with murder in the same way now that they
did then.
But in fact, in some parts of the country,
the murder resolution rate is actually quite
low.
And there's a lot of good research about this.
There's, you know, some more specific ideas
about vehicular homicide being a pretty safe
way to kill someone if you want to murder
them.
That's kind of a more niche topic.
But generally speaking, it's not like murders
are overwhelmingly being solved today, is
it?
Yeah, I mean, there's the continued.
Well, let's be honest about most much a lot
of homicides are you're not talking about,
you know, smart, you know, like carried out
by people who, you know, maybe they're angry
at the time and, you know, there they are
and the police catch them with blood on their
hands.
Yeah.
Of it.
What I'm saying is most homicides are relatively
easy to solve.
You know, I mean, but you're right about the
murder resolution, right.
In terms of the ones that are there that are
more difficult to solve.
You're right.
The raid is not what you would love to like
to see, because words like if you have any
intelligence about it, it's almost easier
to get away with murder if that makes any
sense.
We're going to we're going to go to a break
on the broadcast show, but we're going to
continue our conversation with Jerry Mitchell,
which you can find in full over over on our
YouTube channel,